嘿大家好今天我们要来聊一个很硬核的主题
我们要来深入拆解台股顶尖交易员巨人杰
他最近一场讲座我是交易员里面的核心观面
这个不是随便说说这浓缩了他整整15年的实战精华
哇你看一开始这句话分量就非常重
这不是在跟你讲什么理论
而是他用15年的时间还有好几兆的成交量
真金白银在市场里打滚换来的体悟
所以准备好了吗
接下来的内容你真的要仔细听了
好
那我们今天会分成这四个部分来走
第一心态
这是一切的基础
第二策略
怎么把听到的东西变成能做的
第三执行的核心逻辑
最后也是最关键的
就是部位跟心理层面
这才是决定胜负的地方
好
第一部分心态
在你下任何一笔单之前
你得先问问自己
你现在在做的事情
到底是在赌博
还是在经营一门
可以长长久久的生意
这个差别就是业余跟专业的分水岭
好那先来问个最基本的问题
你每天看的那些交易资讯
是哪来的
是左边这种社群媒体上
很多老师很多故事
还是右边这种
拿得出实际数据的人
你要认真想哦
它到底是靠交易赚钱
还是靠你赚钱
巨人杰就强调
在交易的世界里
唯一能验证的真相
就只有对账单
那为什么那些专业交易员
敢一直下单
敢放大部位
他们的底气是什么
答案就是这个概念
正期望值讲白话一点就是你有一套方法你知道只要你重复做这件事一百次一千次数学上算出来的结果是会赚钱的有了这个交易才是一门生意
不然就只是在赌大小而已
好心态对了
我们来看第二部分策略
你是不是也觉得交易一定要有什么秘密指标
独门心法
其实不用
接下来你会发现
真正厉害的策略
往往就藏在你每天都听到的那些常识里面
来我们举个例子
这个你一定听过
新春开红盘
圆月行情
对不对
每年新闻媒体都在讲
讲到你都腻了
但问题是
然后呢
听完了
你到底要怎么靠这句话
真正在市场上赚到钱
你看哦
这个思考流程其实超有趣
第一步
你听到新闻说胜率很高
第二步
你不能停在这
你要开始问问题
是要买大的还小的
哪个族群不掉会长
然后最关键的第三步
其实超简单
就是图法链钢
你就打开看盘软体
花个一小时
手动去翻一下过去十年的图
你真的就会找到一些规律
最后你就得到一个属于你自己的
可以被验证的交易规则了
所以你懂了吗
关键根本不是去找到什么秘密公式
那种东西不存在
重点是你有没有建立一个框架
一个可以把市场上一句模糊的话
系统性的转变成一个
可以下单的行动计划
这个框架本身才是你真正的保障
好 有了心态 也有了策略框架
接下来第三部分我们要来聊执行
也就是说我们来探讨一下
到底是什么东西在推动市场价格
你搞懂了这个根本原因
才能在关键时刻做出对的判断
居然杰用了一个超棒的比喻
他说你就把交易当成做生意很简单你想 气象报告说台风要来了你会联想到什么哎菜价可能要涨了这背后的logic是什么
没错就是这四个字
供需失衡
这就是所有价格跳动的底层引擎
所以说穿了
你在市场上要做的
就像一个精明的商人一样
去找到那个
哎
这个东西大家抢着要
但货不够了的机会
因为那就是利润的来源
好,那这就带出一个超重要的观念了。
很多人看到股价跌会说,啊,因为跌破月线了。
但你想想看,这是在解释原因,还是在描述一个已经发生的结果。
真正的高手看的是右边这种,像是,哎,像有某个关键零件的报价好像长不动了哦。
这个资讯才是真正会改变大家想法,改变工序的那个触发点。
所以,他才会讲了这句,我觉得很重,但也很真实的话。
这意思不是叫你完全不看K线
而是说
你不要再把所有力气
都花在研究那些图形上了
你应该花更多时间去想
这一根K棒的背后
到底发生了什么事
那个真因才是重点
OK
终于来到最后一部分了
这也是最难
但可以说是最值钱的部分
精通
前面那些你都懂了
但你能不能赚大钱
能不能在市场上活下来
真的就看这里了
问大家一个问题
你觉得交易要进步
是要提高胜率
还是提高你的赚赔比
很多人花一辈子
都在追求那个80%
90%的胜率
但你看这张图
胜率的天花板很低
你再厉害
也很难每次都对
可是赚赔比呢
它的天花板是无限的
这就是为什么
有人可以做到赔一次十块但赚一次赚一千块这才是财富真正放大的关键好那问题来了我知道要放大但我会怕怎么办记住这SOP
这不是靠胆量
是靠流程
第一步
先用一个小小的
亏了你完全不痛的部位进场
这叫做买感觉
然后问自己
嗯这个盘感对吗
如果觉得怪怪的
马上走人
反正也没赔多少
只有在你觉得
哇这个感觉超对的时候
才把真正的部位给压上去
我知道这时候一定有人会说
哎呦用小部位思丹没感觉啦
注意哦
这句话可能就是你没办法进步的关键
因为你打从心底
就没把那个几百块几千块的亏损当成一回事
你必须要练习
就算只是赔了三百块
你也要把它当成赔了三万块一样去检讨
去感觉那个痛
不然你永远学不到教训
最后我们来看一个超级经典的心理陷阱
你看同一个价格回挡一样的K棒
但是你站在不同的位置
你看到的世界就完全不一样
买在低点的人想说
好像变弱了 该跑了
空手的人觉得太棒了 机会来了
而被套在上面的人心里只想着我要加码贪平
那真正的高手他会强迫自己忘掉我买在哪里
然后只问一个最客观的问题
现在这个盘到底是要上还是要下
好 今天讲了这么多
最后我想用巨人节的这句话来说
说真的交易这条路
又累又孤单 压力又大
很多时候能让你一直走下去的
不是什么我要赚大钱的超凡毅力
而是一种很单纯的
你就是很喜欢做这件事的热情
希望今天我们一起拆解的这些观念
能帮助你在这条路上走得更稳更远